hey was mache ich vielleicht für dieses
geile foto
[Musik]
hey leute was genau herzlich willkommen
beim neuen video jahr in dieser tüte
befindet sich gerade ein ausgelaufener
kaffee weil ich habe mir reingefahren
wollte ich jetzt entsorgen und ich habe
vergessen dass da noch was drin ist auf
jeden fall wollen wir schon ungefähr
ein mord und zehn tage
ja wir wollen auf jeden fall schon
ziemlich lange hier und wenn man sich
mal so umschaut vor allem im wohnzimmer
sieht nicht so gut aus also ich muss
noch viel dekoriert werden
hier muss noch einiges hin und das
machen heute oder was sagst du dazu
inszeniert dennoch netz ag otto warburg
mja leute und zwar besteht unser
heutiges einrichtungs kommando aus juri
und auch noch einer weiblichen
begleitung weil das ja eigentlich mal
ganz gut oder und wir fahren jetzt zum
ikea und ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt
was wir so alles schönes finden wir
waren jetzt auch schon recht lange ich
war dort
es wird zeit ich habe bock und ich freue
mich am meisten aufs essen
alex macht den mustern einem monat
gingen
[Musik]
leute wir haben fährt nun 340 und ich
habe noch gar nicht gefrühstückt
deswegen bräuchten jetzt gleich auf ein
leckeres hotdog und im vanilleeis ein
leckeres vortag 1 decke das oder ich
schreibe meine kommentare der oder das
war das geilste juli könnt ihr die
abkürzung zum hot dog stand er ist hier
nämlich jeden tag erstmal vergessen und
danach noch ein orchester immer wieder
hat erst von danach noch ein hotdog zu
essen das finde ich super league vom
juli weil heute geht alles nur weil das
schuldet noch ein bisschen geld
du musst aber selber zahlen
das sieht aus wie die casting couch aus
den pornos oder eben deswegen setze ich
mal dahin thema für uns shoppen sucht
mal was schönes
ja genau es gut sie gut aus so diesen
tisch nehmen wir schon mal mit der sich
gut aus
95 nehmen wir auch drei stück von mit
erleichtert hier 20 euro du bist du
machst ja wann mitarbeiterin tätig böse
angeschaut
[Musik]
das ist einfach dass wir nehmen das
passt wenn es nicht passt wird passend
gemacht schneide ich halt in der mitte
durch ja stimmt so gehackt also wir
haben das jetzt nur besteck gefunden
ich finde das ist noch ausbaufähig leute
ich suche gerade ein bett weil ich
interessiere mich auch für neues bett
irgendwie bin ich glaube ich gerade in
den mädchenzimmer ich habe gerade auf
jeden fall mal so geguckt was sie die
teuersten betten sind und dies ist hier
kostet 2000 euro so recht bequem
vorbeikommende fotografier mal kurz die
vase abdi ist nämlich ganz nett so für
die ecke finde ich die auf jeden fall
schon mal ganz gut
jetzt will ich aber mal was von dir
hören frau einrichtungsexpertin danke
danke ich habe meine fans gefunden
das geld erhält 399 nur sehr wenig
sieht echt süß aus
wir möchten aus dem kinderland abgeholt
werden besteht da kommt julie julia
hiermit kannst du auch mal unendlichen
spiegel gucken so essenspause nummer
zwei metzger hier gibt es keine otto ist
ja ne frechheit da musst du dich so ein
wir brauchen neues sich zwei sachen
gleichzeitig transportieren so wir
brauchen noch teller ist schon geil
hallo wenn ihr euch wissen wir dass ich
mal ganz schön wenn man das ja auf jeden
fall wirklich klar besser sagte er in
den links war ja dann nimmt das mit ja
dann nehmen wir die erfolgreichen aber
länglichen ich bin eigentlich wieder den
kurs auf ich bin eigentlich für diese
hier so wir haben zeit gefunden weil
pack malen
super jetzt haben wir auf jeden fall
alles außer decken
[Musik]
aber jetzt ja das gut
da kann das ganze programm könnt jetzt
so auch im kühlschrank drauf stellen
juli das hier nehmen wir auch mit so ich
bin eigentlich gegen seinen kumpel aber
wir brauchen jetzt ein kurzes aber es
ist trotzdem eine wohnung nehmen
wie kommt ins wohnzimmer in unser
schönes grund zu machen
alex setzt sich mal hier vorne sein das
passt da nicht rein
[Musik]
das vielleicht aber nicht ich komm wir
suchen jetzt auch verkaufskosten willst
du willst blumen in den fernseher tun
teelichter so2say was macht also leute
werden uns alles soweit eingekauft
und jetzt müssen wir in diesen dummen
lager noch alle tische finden die wir
noch nicht gefunden haben oder nicht
mitnehmen konnten wollen wir auch noch
einen tisch für unseren fernseher und
daraus im angebot bin immer mit wir sind
noch günstiger zehn euro für den
klappstuhl vom das direkt zehn nehmen
und was sagst du selbst für gute
entscheidung wie viele likes auf diesem
video für dieses foto das kommt bei uns
ist für meinen blog schreiben kommentare
us- blöd wie viele likes für dieses
geile foto
so leute wir sind jetzt endlich nach
zehn jahren auch mal fertig haben
mittlerweile 17 uhr an sind wir da
angekommen
wir haben da drei stunden drin wir haben
jetzt für 600 euro die kuh gekauft und
auch so einen tisch und ich habe mir auf
jeden fall überlegt demnächst mehr neues
bett zu kaufen aber da muss ich noch ein
placement wie viel geld hast du
ausgegeben
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob wir das
alles da rein kriegen ist possible junge
das besser englisch heute folgendes
problem dieses bild ist zu groß es geht
nicht um ein auto rein
es passt einfach nicht ins auto
unübersichtlich was machen würden
[Musik]
sechseinhalb stunden später
wir haben das bild jetzt drin und alle
anderen auch so leute nach gefühlt 20
stunden sind jetzt auch wieder zu hause
wir haben ja eingerichtet erzählt jetzt
eigentlich echt cool aus als ich bin
zufrieden ja leute aber bevor ich euch
das zeige würde ich erst mal sagen wenn
ihr bock auf der rücktour das vertrauen
da ich würde sagen bei 12.000 uhr allein
schon dieses schild da oben ist finde
ich ziemlich geil den rest sage ich euch
dann wenn ihr bock drauf gehabt und wir
sehen uns dann morgen wieder morgen
gibt's neues video habe 36 naturals
überhaupt nicht vergessen
[Musik]